first of all hello welcome back to Yale
my name is Steven Latham I'm the deputy
director of the Yale interdisciplinary
Center for Bioethics we we sit near the
forestry school I teach undergraduate
courses in bioethics and law and I have
colleagues who teach philosophical and
moral theological bioethics courses to
undergrads I also teach some healthcare
school of management mid-career
executives about ethics in health care
systems so that's who I am
and my talk is called this year in
bioethics I have a good job okay and
what I'm going to do is - through a
number of topics in bioethics and I will
really - through them and then open up
for you all to ask questions about
whichever ones might be most interesting
to you so first of all that's Yale's
interdisciplinary Center for Bioethics
we have our own little house as I said
up on Prospect Street far away on campus
from the medical school as is possible
but that's okay because it's actually
very healthy for everyone to walk back
and forth we also do we do some teaching
over there and we have a number of
medical school faculty who are part of
our Center there's a lot of back and
forth there all right now today I'm
going to rush through the following many
topics a life spans worth of topics and
beyond I'm going to say I'm gonna start
pre-birth talking about human embryonic
stem cells then both cesarean sections
childhood vaccinations adulthood
post-traumatic stress disorder and then
a little bit about obesity patient
decision aids and end-of-life physician
assisted suicide and beyond the beyond
is synthetic biology since that has
nothing to do with our lifespan it has
instead to do with recent stories about
the creation of life in the laboratory
which are actually quite interesting so
as you see there are many topics I'm
going to spend I hope maybe two minutes
so that we have discussion time at the
end this is from 30,000 feet at quite a
pace so let's begin that's a human
embryonic stem cell and that's my first
topic and I'll tell you a little bit
about them they are human embryonic stem
cells are human cells and they are
embryonic in the sense that they have
been removed from an embryo in vitro in
a petri dish and they are pluripotent
because the multi cells say eight celled
pre embryo in the petri dish has the
ability to grow up to be a baby right
each one of those cells in there has the
ability to specialize and become any
kind of cell in a human body a nerve
cell a pancreatic cell a blood platelet
whatever it may be so these cells in the
petri dish are very special because as
yet they're undifferentiated they're all
identical but if they are coaxed
properly by being exposed to different
proteins and things they can actually
specialize into various kinds of adult
cells which is why researchers think
that they are that they hold out a lot
of promise they're also immortal in the
sense that if you reproduce them in the
Patriot ish and get more and more of
them their telomeres don't shrink the
cells themselves don't go through
cellular aging as they multiply and
divide so you can from a single human
embryonic stem cell you can make a dish
full of them and then you can make a
thousand dishes full of them and you can
send them to researchers around the
world and indeed that is what's
happening with human embryonic stem
cells the lines are in international
traffic around the world so that
researchers in different parts of the
globe are working with genetically
identical material in doing their
research so they can duplicate or
challenge one another's research in that
way so of course the core ethical issue
is that they are human and embryonic and
therefore some people assimilate the
destruction of the embryo in the petri
dish to abortion or indeed to the murder
of a child because this is an entity
that has all the genetic
components of human being here's in
research human embryonic stem cells are
useful for a couple of reasons the first
is the most important and it doesn't get
a lot of publicity and that is testing
drugs because for example we have a
researcher here at Yale who uses human
embryonic stem cells coaxes them forward
by exposing them to different agents
proteins she makes them into liver cells
thousands and thousands of identical
human liver cells that did not come from
a living human donor didn't require
surgery to remove from anyone and those
liver cells then she can expose drugs to
them and see how human liver metabolizes
drugs so you can use for human embryonic
stem cells to speed up and enhance the
safety of drug testing and if we're
going to see a therapeutic result from
human embryonic stem cells in the short
term it'll be because of drug production
the thing that gets oh it a little note
there the need for disease to tissue
what you might want to do is test drugs
on tissue that has genetic disease so
you use a human embryonic stem cell that
has a genetic disease because the embryo
it came from how to genetic disease and
then you can test to see how drugs
affect the expression of that disease at
the cellular level alright next custom
tissue generation as the therapy for
cellular disease this is the thing that
gets most publicity you can take a human
embryonic stem cell and coax it forward
into becoming say a pancreatic cell of
the sort that helps us regulate our
blood sugar levels it's possible then
that we could manufacture replacement
cells for people and create cures for
diabetes or for Parkinson's or for a
number of diseases that occur at the
cellular failure kind of level the
problem is that if you make these
replacement cells using a human
embryonic stem cell this kind of
research has been done in mice for
example replacement cells have been made
and put in mice replacement cells for
spinal column injury and so on with
problem is that the bodies reject them
because they aren't our own in the same
way that you might reject a donated
organ your body says oh this is a
foreign thing and sends all the white
cells after it to get rid of it well
that may be resolvable by combining
human embryonic stem cell research with
cloning the idea is I take a cell of
yours I pop the nucleus out I put that
in in place of the nucleus of an egg
allow it to multiply to about the eight
cell stage when it's very small it's
smaller the whole thing is smaller than
a the period at the end of a sentence in
a printed book but you dismantle that
into its component cells and make
embryonic stem cell lines from those
component cells and every one of those
embryonic stem cell lines now has your
genetic makeup because the nucleus for
that egg was taken from you and that
means if we now manufacture a cell to
help cure your diabetes your body will
greet it at it as its own so the
possibility is out there and it's many
years hence but the possibility is there
that embryonic stem cells could be used
to create replacement cells genetically
tailor-made for people
with cellular based diseases there's
another possibility of resolving the
rejection problem by parthenogenesis and
I'll say a word about this because it
comes up in the next slide or so
positive Genesis means you take an egg
that's not fertilized and you coax it
into splitting up as if it were an
embryo and it takes some doing and this
doesn't occur naturally with any mammals
though it does occur in nature with
frogs
for example the egg without being
fertilized can't spontaneously start to
split and then you can make human
embryonic stem cell lines from these
splits now there's no possibility with
mammals or with humans that the parson
oat can ever become an infant right they
don't they aren't they don't have enough
genetic material to do that but you can
make embryonic stem cell lines out of it
and then you can use the stem cell lines
to make replacement cells and those
cells since they only have a mom and not
that have only half as many of what are
called histocompatibility antigens that
means there are only half as many points
that your body can reject as being not
its own when you transplant something
into your body so that a partha note
cell stands twice as good a chance if
you like as an ordinary cell from
someone else as not to not be rejected
by your body if that makes sense
all right so so let's move on why is
this in this year in bioethics this is
an issue that's been going on for some
time well because this year President
Obama announced the NIH funding scheme
for doing research with stem cells and
here's what he's said he said that he
will fund research on stem cell lines
only if they have been developed from
leftover embryos from fertility clinics
in vitro fertilization commonly leaves
extra embryos because you you make more
in case the couple doesn't get pregnant
on the first try or the second trial you
have extras there are more than 400,000
excess embryos in the United States
right now in freezers I have to chunk of
them the embryo creating parents have
consented for their use in research so
those will research on stem cell lines
that are created from those leftover
embryos will be funded by the Obama NIH
this is in contrast to President Bush
who would only fund lines that already
existed when he announced his funding
scheme because you didn't want federal
monies to be implicated in the
destruction of future embryos President
Obama is permitting federal money to be
used as long as the embryos come from
these fertility clinics neither under
Obama nor under Bush nor going back to
President Clinton in 93 can you use any
federal money actually to split up the
embryo and destroy it and create the
stem cell lines that's been no federal
funding for the creation of the lines
you have to get foundation money or
private money
or state money like from the state of
Connecticut which funds human embryonic
stem cell research
you make the line with that money and
then you can go to NIH and get research
money after the line has been created
the idea again is that federal money
shouldn't be implicated in the
destruction of embryos because so so
many people feel so strongly about that
issue President Obama won't fund any
research on lines that are created in
the lab which means a diseased line that
you actually create in order to test the
disease instead you're gonna have to
troll through the IVF clinic excess
embryos to see if any of them have the
genetic diseases that you're interested
in in order to do federally funded
research and President Obama won't fund
work on partha notes or on cloning lines
that were created through
parthenogenesis or through cloning and
there are two reasons one is and the NIH
published this when they published the
funding rules one is they said there's
not as much agreement about the idea
that it's okay to create an embryo and
then destroy it for research purposes
these leftover IVF clinic embryos at
least we know that if they aren't used
in research they will eventually be
destroyed so fewer people object to
using them in research but to make an
embryo in the lab and then destroy it
seems to many people to be more
offensive so that's one consideration
but that doesn't explain part the notes
for example which aren't really embryos
they can't ever become a human being
even if they were implanted the
reasoning there and here again it's
something NIH said in its publicity the
reasoning there seems to be that we
don't want to have the federal
government involved in paying women to
donate eggs because to donate an egg is
actually quite a procedure for whether
for fertility or for research but we
don't want the US government going out
and putting women through this very
invasive hormonal treatment that makes
them produce more eggs and then surgery
that takes the eggs from them the Obama
administration has just decided not to
go there I note at the very same time as
the state of New York has just decided
actually that they approve of the idea
of paying women for their eggs so the
situation in this country
that sort of overall situation is that
we have incredibly liberal research laws
nothing isn't permitted whereas there
are some countries like Austria or
Ireland where it's actually illegal to
conduct certain kinds of embryonic
research but in the u.s. you can do
everything the only question is where do
you go to get funding for it is that the
federal government is that the state
government is a private foundation and
that also reflects how much funding is
available for it
finally the Obama administration has
restrictions on funding research that
involves mixing the genetic material of
humans and animals they particularly
don't want to fund mixes of human and
animal genetic material that will find
their way into the germline in other
words be passed on to the children of
the research embryo that you're creating
as far as I know there aren't many
people are actually interested in doing
that kind of research so that
restriction is is not very painful to
research scientists there are scientists
who do want to mix human and animal
material but they want to mix them at
the cellular level to see what happens
for example you can do a lot of basic
stem cell research
using a cow egg or a frog egg and
putting human genetic material into that
and then producing stem cells in the
petri dish but they all get destroyed
after a few days it's just less
expensive and less difficult to obtain a
cow egg than to get a woman to donate
egg for research so there are animal
animal human mixtures being used in the
labs but nobody has the island of dr.
Moreau in mind nobody's trying to make
you know the Pinky and the brain Mouse
with the human personality or all that
so right now I spent probably the most
time on this topic and I'll move through
my next topics more quickly cesarean
sections this is a the expression to
posh to push has found its way into the
British press and here's here's why it
was just announced that the u.s.
c-section rate is the highest of this is
data from 2007 but they've just been
crunched and really
31.8% of american birth sir by c-section
that's crazy hi Brazil is ahead of us
with a higher rate but the w-h-o has
looked at this and and sort of made an
estimate that that the healthiest rate
in terms of avoiding problems with
natural childbirth and not doing
excessive surgery is around 15% so we're
really really high and the question is
why and one answer that you find in the
literature and of course in the popular
press is this to posh to push answer
which is that women and particularly
comparatively wealthy career women are
demanding c-sections because they can be
scheduled you can say alright I'm having
this baby on a Tuesday right
and there's also some question that some
women might fear side effects of natural
birth there's a little bit more problem
in the short run with incontinence I
believe with natural birth and there is
also just the what might be just the
fear of the labor process itself which
as I'm sure some of you know is not
comfortable so this is where the line to
posture push comes from and I will say
that in the medical literature in the
medical literature every every c-section
that doesn't have a medical indication
in the recent years the medical
literature has referred to these
routinely as cesarean section on
maternal demand or cesarean section on
maternal request as if every non
medically indicated c-section was
because mom asked for it okay however
and I've published an article about this
not long ago however there's a lot of
data around that shows that c-sections
happen more on Fridays that they that
there's difference between daytime and
evening rates of c-sections even within
the same medical practice that
c-sections go up when reimbursement for
procedures is higher
then reimbursement for natural
childbirth to the physicians that
physicians sometimes perform c-sections
because they're afraid of malpractice
you can you can't it's easier to say I
did everything if you've performed a
procedure than if you've just been
standing there watching what happened
right or at least that's the logic and
there are certain practices that seem to
just habitually recommend c-sections
more often than others it might be the
personalities of physicians in different
areas that are driving this now what's
the proportion of these that are that
result from maternal request and what's
the proportion that result from
physicians projecting their preferences
on to women and does anyone including
the physician or the woman know which is
which all the time we don't know but the
the main theme of my article was we
should stop referring in the literature
to these as all resulted from maternal
demand because at least some of them
don't some research has been done in
Brazil that shows that women going in to
pregnancy in Brazil all say they want
natural childbirth and after
conversations with their physicians
Brazil has the highest c-section rate in
the world 36 or something like that all
right next topic vaccinations this man
is Andrew Wakefield a few years ago
Andrew Wakefield published an article in
The Lancet Journal that claimed to find
a link between the onset of autism and
the triple measles mumps rubella
vaccination that was then being given
he had very poor of scientific design
there were only a dozen kids involved in
this trial numerous researchers around
the world have attempted to duplicate
this research and have not been able to
and indeed this research and some of the
actual charts from the article now show
up in the medical literature as examples
of misleading ways to present research
findings recently this year in two
different one three months ago or so
Andrew Wakefield lost his medical
license in the UK because he was
convicted by the
licensing board of having committed
various kinds of fraud in connection
with the publication of this article and
also failing to disclose before he even
did the article that he was in pay for
some plaintiffs attorneys but by some
plaintiffs attorneys who represented
parents with autism who were trying to
blame drug companies for their
children's autism and he did not declare
this anywhere in the course of producing
or publishing the article so he has lost
his medical license and the article
itself was d published by Lancet they've
gone back and said that's not ours
anymore they've taken it out of the
electronic database and put up a little
notice saying no no no this doesn't
exist ten of the twelve co-authors on
this piece have also now disavowed its
findings and written separate letters
saying that it was a mistake to publish
it and to spin the results the way they
did nonetheless a lot of damage was done
vaccination rates in the UK which had
been up in the 95 percent range which is
well enough to give everyone herd
immunity from these childhood diseases
plummeted down to something in the 60s
and in parts of London even hit below
50% vaccination rate because parents
were afraid of giving their children
autism and we had deaths from measles in
the UK for the first time in something
like 13 years not only from measles but
from encephalitis related to measles and
a couple other things so we had serious
sir and incidents of measles and mumps
rose dramatically after this conviction
this year it seems as if the the anti
vaccination fervor has reduced a little
bit and the vaccination rates in the UK
are starting to rise a little bit there
was an effect here in the United States
of this publicity as well you might have
seen Jenny McCarthy the former Playboy
model who until recently was married to
Jim Carrey the comic actor she was going
around talking about vaccinations autism
connections and that has had an impact
on vaccination in the United States so
one question we might ask is what should
we do about this kind of thing in
connection with our vaccine policy
there's a
right off between the public health
benefits of vaccinations and liberty
right some people have religious reasons
to not want vaccinations other people
just have reasons about fear they don't
want the vaccinations how far should we
respect that the answer so far is that
in the US there's wide wide variability
on that question Colorado I believe it
is has a very liberal release from
vaccine you send in a note from the
parents and your child doesn't have to
have the school vaccine New York I think
you need to see either one physician
twice or two different physicians to get
an excuse to get out of the vaccine
program so we have wide variability and
in the states where it's easy to get out
of public vaccination vaccination rates
have reduced recently because in part of
this autism scare we have last year we
had a little kerfuffle in Virginia and
in Texas over the vaccine for human
papillomavirus HPV causes cervical
cancer we now know the cervical cancer
many varieties of cervical cancer are
sexually transmitted and if you
vaccinate boys and girls and not just
girls because it's sexually transmitted
you vaccinate the boys and the girls for
HPV and you can dramatically and reduce
the instance not only of cervical cancer
but also of genital warts and some other
unpleasant sexually transmitted diseases
but a couple of states tried to add the
HPV vaccination to the mandatory school
vaccine program and the parents went
ballistic because of course it's a
vaccine against sexually transmitted
diseases and the clear implication is
that your child is going to be sexually
active at a relatively young age now the
public health statistics confirm that
your child is going to be sexually
active or at least statistically it's
quite likely but many parents are
offended by that and many parents then
what may turn and withdraw their
children entirely
from the vaccine program not just from
this one but from the whole thing and
then we have months okay so there's an
interesting kind of ethical question
about where we should go with the
balance between individual liberty and
public health and how we should tailor
the vaccine program to make it as
effective as possible and as inoffensive
to people who really are worried about
these things really trying to protect
their kids so next issue post-traumatic
stress disorder
we had a report earlier this year that
incidents of PTSD is skyrocketing the
military is very worried about this with
our troops coming home from Iraq and
Afghanistan
apparently the levels of PTSD coming
home from Iraq and Afghanistan are much
higher even than the levels that we saw
after the Vietnam War not only that but
we know the prevalence is up because of
our returning troops the diagnosis is
also up too and we know that the rates
are actually higher among rape and abuse
victims for example than they are among
people returning from the battlefield
there also seems to be an enhanced
susceptibility of women to PTSD for some
reason that people don't really have a
good handle on but women and men in the
same stressful situation the woman is
more apt to get the symptoms that
characterize PTSD the definition of PTSD
is a little bit in flux this year also
the American Psychiatric Association is
coming out with their update for their
diagnosis manual and they're adjusting
the definition of post-traumatic stress
disorder to include things like a kind
of secondhand trauma in other words you
don't have to be the person who is on
the firing line it might be enough if
you were exposed to repeated images of
the traumatic event for you to suffer
PTSD and of course the debate there is
well some people say this is clinically
justified because they see patients who
have the the symptoms the depression and
the anger and their uncontrollability
and the reliving and the night sweats
and all the things that go with PTSD
they see
patience who for example have seen many
many times the videos of people leaping
out the windows on 9/11 alright and that
they weren't there they weren't at the
scene they didn't witness it but having
seen it at a distance a number of times
they're experiencing the post-traumatic
stress symptoms well some people think
that that definition needs to be wider
so more people can be brought into the
health system and have their symptoms
treated and other people worry about
criterion creep and about how this is
going to show up in the courtroom as
causes of action for damages and so on
so some of the interesting ethical
issues here are that one way you can
prevent PTSD is by giving people beta
blockers either before an anticipated
traumatic experience like just before
you go out into the battlefield or just
after and beta blockers aren't any kind
of exotic crazy medicine they're pretty
normal and we understand their effects
but what they do is they allow you to
retain the memory of the event separated
from a lot of its emotional and
psychological impact it's a little bit
there's a sort of film of objective
distance between you and your own memory
is that good medicine or is it creepy
right are we are we saving people from
developing symptoms yes we are of a very
debilitating psychological it's like a
psychiatric condition but we are also in
some ways people worry about diminishing
the emotional impact on the battlefield
might reduce soldiers guilt it might
enhance commanders willingness to send
their troops into more stressful
situations it might reduce the
self-control of military and others
first responders and so on in stressful
situations it might also be undermining
something that we think of as important
for personality right the emotional
content of an event is part of what it
is to have an important event in your
memory and and dealing with that makes
it part of your personality
but we don't want people walking around
with the debilitating symptoms of PTSD
so there's an interesting ethical
dilemma there's also problems about the
use of animal studies in PTSD because we
do animal studies where we stress out
the animals and expose them to trauma
and try to see what happens to their
different levels of hormones and how
their brains respond we do brain scans
on them and so on and of course animal
rights activists look at this and say
well you know animal brains aren't that
great a model for human brains
is it really worth this kind of cruelty
to get results that don't really map
that well onto human brains
that's another issue and finally there's
the question of if you if you screened
for PTSD and diagnosed with it but
there's no treatment haven't you just
upped the risk of stigmatization without
actually conferring any benefit you've
given someone a name to be called
perhaps but not necessarily confer to
benefit now there people are talking
about the possibility of treatment
through reliving the traumatic
experience that seems to reduce some of
the symptoms so it may be that this
problem is going away because we are
coming up with better ways to relieve
the symptoms of PTSD obesity the next
topic and I am
this one's quick obviously it's a huge
problem we don't really understand why
people are becoming obese there's a
genetic component there's huge
environmental components about what
kinds of food are available to people
what kinds of time they have to eat that
food
the patterns in which we eat our food
are not very good for us as it turns out
the kinds of exercise facilities or
environments they have available to them
and so on there's also some speculation
that the microbes we have in our guts
have a lot to do with how we deal with
food more of the genetic material in
your body belongs to the foreign
microbes that live in you and on you
than actually belong to you that's the
kind of sobering thought you're not
actually you're not actually a person
you're just kind of a home
for a really big colony and and you
could not live without these little
colonists they're digesting your food
for you for example and there are
millions of them they're on your skin
they're in your sinuses they're
throughout you and they're doing a lot
of work we live with these creatures
well some of them may have something to
do with the way we handle our food and
some people I mean there are
speculations that it might even be the
relationship between some causes of
obesity and antibiotics that have killed
things in our guts that actually we
should have kept around because they're
helpful anyway we don't really
understand all the causes of obesity and
we do a lot of blaming the victim you
must be fat because you eat too much
because you don't exercise too much you
watch TV late at night and everyone
wants to tell you that this is actually
in your control if only you buy my
product you will be thin but for some
people there isn't that level of control
so so here are these interventions we
can use to control people's cigarette
smoking habits oops I mean their obesity
alright there's I make a little public
health point with my slides here the
interventions are exactly the same the
the menu of interventions are exactly
the same we can try to push for
individual habit changes by publicity
and education we can try to do
individual medical interventions like
bariatric you know these things we can
provide labels and information then the
Obama health plan includes calorie
labeling for all fast-food chains if you
own more than six fast-food stores you
have to provide calorie laving you'll
see it shortly in a in a Starbucks and a
McDonald's and a Dunkin Donuts near you
and the fast food industry wanted it
because they saw it coming at the state
level and they thought we'd rather have
one federal standard for reporting
calories than 50 state standards right
so that's coming as part of health
reform we can tax foods that are bad for
us the same way we tax cigarettes and
alcohol we can regulate the actual
content of foods the way New York for
example was the first mover in banning
trans fats
foods we can establish tort liabilities
for people who produce foods that are
bad for us in the way that people tried
to establish tort wealth there has been
tort liability for cigarettes and people
have tried it with things like handguns
less successfully it was quite
successful with cigarettes we can and we
can try to do all these things and
create a massive social repositioning
around the issue of obesity which is
what we've done with cigarettes it's now
kind of illegal to have a cigarette in
your hand in most places in the United
States and it could be you know I the
future might hold mandatory salads or
something but we could we could try to
move public culture in that way and
finally we could try to get food
companies actually to see that the
market is moving and they want to reform
and change their products to meet a
market that is starting to care more
than before about problems related to
obesity and food-related health we see
some of this happening already with the
publicity and the popularity of Michael
Pollan's books and the Food Inc movie
and so on it's out there supersize me or
supersize this whatever yeah there's
there's already some move toward massive
social change on this issue I'll do this
very quickly another thing in the health
care act that you might have heard of
health care reform at is a training
program to get physicians to learn how
to use patient decision aids this is
where a patient has to make a decision
between say having a surgical
intervention or handling the same
problem with drugs or you know there are
lots of for prostate cancer given the
very slow rate at which it accelerates
and the possibility of harms from the
surgery itself some people want to just
do watchful waiting and some people want
the aggressive intervention these
patient decision aids inform you about
what the options are and what the risks
are or that's the idea and they're
probably in the Obama health care plan
this pilot project to educate physicians
in their use is probably in there
the
cause the rap on patient decision aids
is that if you tell patients what the
options are they tend to choose the less
aggressive interventions and that means
it's a cost saving thing now this was
one of the many features of the Obama
health care plan that got denounced as
death panels because the the idea was
that if you give patients decision aids
about end-of-life care
we'll get rid of them sooner you know
and pretty soon we'll will be deciding
to do away with people and so on but
there if you go on the web and look at
patient decision aids and the Obama
health reform it's characterized by some
people as this death panel thing really
what it is is an effort to put into the
patient's hands more of the facts about
treatment decisions they have to make so
they can make up their own minds but
it's being pushed because they tend or
that or studies a few studies show not
many but a few studies show that they
save costs but maybe they save costs
because their production has largely
been paid for so far by insurance
companies maybe they're biased to save
cost maybe the information they contain
is designed to get patients to make
those choices well and we know that from
some of some of the studies that show
that they save costs don't take into
account the actual cost of producing the
decision aid so at the end of the day it
may be that they don't save complete
cost to the healthcare system but they
are encouraging patients to take the
less invasive intervention so can we
make better ones that don't have the
Spy's can we measure bias is it real
there are rumors abounded and that's a
series of interesting questions
physician assisted suicide why is that
happening this year for a couple of
reasons number one the UK has just
changed its assisted suicide policy the
prosecutorial authorities in the UK have
decided that if you help a terminally
ill loved one to commit suicide perhaps
by taking them over to Switzerland where
it's mostly legal or perhaps by helping
them get a lethal dosage of pills if you
help them and their terminally ill and
their
competent and they've asked for your
assistance the prosecutorial authorities
in the UK will not prosecute you for
assisted suicide the criminal offense
this is brand-new this year in the
United States last year Washington State
put an assisted suicide program in place
that's modeled on its neighbor Oregon's
10 year old assisted suicide program and
last time I looked there had been 36
Washingtonians who had taken lethal
pills to end their lives under the
Washington plan Oregon is steady at
around 50 or 55 people per year over the
last decade committing suicide at the
end of a difficult round of disease
cancer ALS and some others here in
Connecticut we have a lawsuit
challenging the assisted suicide
criminal statute here asking that the
court decide that the Connecticut
legislature never intended that statute
to apply to the actions of doctors in
end-of-life care with terminally ill
patients we'll see whether that goes
anywhere it got a little bit of
emotional boost in Connecticut recently
that that lawsuit did because a couple
in North Haven she with Alzheimer's and
he with cancer I believe he shot her and
then shot himself and this became
unfortunately in a way it became part of
this assisted suicide debate their
question was you know if is this is this
kind of tragedy a reason why we need
physician assisted suicide or an example
of the things can that can go wrong if
you allow people to kill themselves
instead of get good compassionate care
when they're in extreme illness anyway
it's been quite a debate around here
this year I'm not gonna this is the
Oregon Death with Dignity Act these are
all the steps you have to go through
before you're allowed to get the lethal
pills just to save time I'm just going
to tell you there are a lot of steps you
see you see a couple of doctors you're
not depressed you the your requite you
have to request independently you have
to be competent your
have to be two weeks apart and you have
to be able to take the pills yourself
it's not euthanasia where someone else
injects you at the end you have the
pills you take them that's how it works
so there are a lot of protections in
place in Oregon and now in Washington
and a lot of ethical issues is there
something intrinsically wrong with
suicide even as a way out of terrible
end-of-life illness and symptoms is it a
bad role for physicians to play to be
involved in helping people dodge
shouldn't we keep their hands clean of
that we'll physician-assisted suicide be
used in lieu of good end of life care
for minorities or for less educated
populations who don't communicate as
well or as readily with their physicians
or for patients who don't have family
support around to argue for them will
that will we will we give patients death
instead of good care because it's easier
and you can predict that it would be the
the that the exploitation would land on
more vulnerable patients lower
socioeconomic class perhaps with mental
illness and so on that's been one of the
big worries in Oregon that worry has not
come true in Oregon it's mostly pretty
well educated people know
african-americans in Oregon have used
the program if you know the geography of
Oregon it's all the people who live on
in the liberal sophisticated coastal
cities inland Oregon does not commit
suicide and and it's mostly the people
who do it also are people who have some
levels of family support they're people
who have been married
rather than loners and they are mostly
majority white patients not minorities
and so we haven't seen big examples of
exploitation in Oregon under the plan
although some people have claimed that
in one case there was someone who was
depressed and should have had
psychiatric care instead of assisted
suicide but remember to qualify in
Oregon you also have to have two doctors
who have already diagnosed you terminal
which means the expectation is you'll be
dead in six months in any case
so now my last topic synthetic biology
this is a really recent hot topic some
of you may have seen this it was a cover
story of time I think and the economists
last week ah a scientist called craig
Venter made the first living cellular
organism with entirely lab but
manufactured DNA
he took bits of DNA from the lab spliced
them together by looking at a live model
of a bacterium he searched spliced
together the DNA to match the DNA he saw
in the live cell put that DNA into the
husk of an enucleated microorganism and
it took off started reproducing is alive
reproduces digests food has a little
mono cellular life of its own entirely
synthetically manufactured DNA in a way
given the state of the science of
synthetic biology this was not that big
a deal people are doing things like this
all the time and have been for years but
it was a brilliant stroke of publicity
and it really did get the attention of
the world because it is the first time
you can say there's a life-form whose
DNA was laboratory manufactured from
spare parts what else has been going on
in synthetic biology well there's been a
lot of advanced genetic engineering
where we take out little bits of cells
and put in other things to try to make
the cells metabolize differently to try
to make them like to eat things that we
would like to have eaten like oil and
there's been a project called BioBricks
that involves breaking down DNA of cells
into of microbes and things into little
strips which seem to have isolable
functions and the idea is these
BioBricks you'll be able to take some of
this and some of that and put them
together and make the microbe of your
choice from a menu there's a BioBricks
website that has kind of open source
here are the things we've been able to
identify and they're up listed and you
can get these spare parts and try it's
like Lego you can make your own
with it then there's minimal genome
creation where they actually take a
living creature and they try to remove
the bits of the DNA that don't seem to
be doing anything that aren't expressing
in humans that's most the DNA we have
doesn't seem to do anything that we know
about but you can go in and remove it
and the idea is to make as small a
chassis as possible onto it you'll then
be able to stick your BioBricks
features okay so this is about the
business of manufacturing novel
life-forms that have never been seen in
the lab for various kinds of
applications including medical
applications new drugs living medicines
that can go in and I don't know devour
the deposits of plaque on the walls of
your veins or you know we can think of
different features for creating
creatures that have been genetically
tailored in industry one of the biggest
things we're talking about is using
these microbes to create biofuels
particularly in the developing world in
agriculture you can use them for
pesticides or to create new food
additives using this synthetic biology
environment I mentioned already the idea
of having creatures that go devour oil
you let them loose on the oil spill and
they they metabolize the oil and then
and and clean up for us or you could
imagine and some people are talking
about creating new creatures that have
very high co2 absorption rates to pull
greenhouse gases out of the atmosphere
and you can also just use them to
explore interesting pure biological
questions about how cells work and how
DNA works
lots of ethics issues up at the top are
security and safety these things could
be used to make bio terror weapons novel
cellular phones the forms that do bad
things to us it's not expensive to make
this stuff happen you don't need a lot
of fancy lab equipment to do it
safety people are worried about things
escaping from the lab and then evolving
in the wild and becoming you know
hazardous creatures some people worry
about social dislocation for a new
industries particularly biofuel
manufacture in the developing world will
this be the new bananas where we're sort
of forcing a mono call
our new industry on partners in the
developing world and will there be
social dislocation from that or economic
dislocation and then there's this very
abstract but in some way interesting
idea that this shouldn't be done because
it involves playing God and this is an
ill-defined worry people think about
what that means very differently but
there's some sense that some people have
that making novel life forms even for
good purposes is somehow beyond the
scope of what it is that we human beings
ought to be involved in at all
it's hubristic and this is a separate
worry from the possibility of bad
consequences like it'll get out of our
control now it's a separate worry about
whether we people are transgressing some
kind of boundary about how much control
we should be trying to exerting to
trying to exert over the world all right
so Yale bioethics by complete
coincidence has projects going on
involving every topic I've talked to you
about today a couple of our members are
on the state stem cell committee and on
the Yale escrow which is the board that
oversees stem cell research here at Yale
Medical School I've mentioned my
publication on c-sections we have a risk
assessment working group that's been
working on the HPV vaccine risk question
we have a post-traumatic stress disorder
working group that's about to publish a
collection of essays on social and
economic and legal aspects of PTSD we
have project on the ethics of
nutritional research on human subjects
we're trying to develop some new patient
decision aids if we get the grant and a
couple of us are involved in a state
brief on aid in dying for this case that
I mentioned that's been brought in
Connecticut and finally we have a
partnership with the Hastings Center the
Hastings Center is the main lead
think-tank in bioethics in the world and
we now have a Yale Hastings joint
program in ethics and health policy and
the Hastings Center is way ahead of the
game on synthetic biology and very
involved in that kind of stuff and
there's so much more find out more about
please by coming to our website which is
yale.edu slash bioethics now I actually
managed to leave a little time for some
questions so you know not much time but
10 minutes or something OOP that's
that's not what I want that's what I
want so questions comments yes yes yes
yeah we have had yes I'll repeat the
question the question the the first part
of the question was am I worried that
our technology is ahead of our ethics
and a couple of examples were things
like in connection with assisted
reproduction we have a lot of male sperm
donors they don't know how many children
they're having there was a newspaper
story last year about two people who
couldn't get married because it emerged
after they had been courting one another
that they were in fact products that the
same father sperm donor and they had met
socially and one result now is that the
clinics are shipping the donated sperm
across the country to avoid children
being born of parents don't know parents
concentrated in one area just for this
kind of reason and what was the other
example you yeah right so there's
there's questions about if you donate an
egg or if you donate an embryo to
research and 15 years from now it
emerges that that embryo was used to do
something that you now disapprove of or
you donate an egg and then a child is
born and what do you tell the child
about the donor that lot of question I
think as a lawyer who kind of follows
some of this stuff I think we're moving
in the direction of just complete
openness about all these very new and
strange parental relationships
we had a wonderful case in California a
few years ago where a couple who was
infertile wanted a child and they were
both I guess infertile because they got
an egg donor mom who was married and a
sperm donor father who was married and
the embryo was implanted in a surrogate
mother who was married so the couple had
no biological relationship at all
including carrying the child - the child
is being born
well of course while the surrogate is
pregnant the couple split up and they
say we want no part of this anymore
so so the California Court gets this
case in the California Court with eight
parents to choose from says that this
child has no parents and it is a ward of
the state on appeal the appellate court
said no the contracting couple who set
this in motion has financial
responsibility for this child and is the
parent it's not donor dad or egg donor
mom or their spouses it's not surrogate
mom or her husband it's the contracting
couple who have the problem and then the
surrogate mom adopted the child so the
case was resolved in a kind of nice way
the mother who had carried the child's
term adopted the child but what what do
you say to that child about who are
mommy and daddy I I think that I think
that the direction we're moving in is
that what you say to them is your sperm
donor was so and so and here's he lives
in Sacramento and your egg donor was
so-and-so she's from Merced I was your
surrogate mom and I now I'm your real
mom right cuz that's alright I think
that's the direction we're going in
we're the UK has recently abolished
anonymous sperm donation we haven't done
that yet here but I think we will be I
think we're moving the direction of
complete openness and people will start
to and in fact a lot of the clinic's
fertility clinics are already doing this
they won't help couples who don't plan
to include the donor parents at least by
release of their medical information and
biography to the child the clinics are
coming up with this policy on their own
it's not a requirement of law but that's
direction another question yes sir they
are not doing it
prophylactically before the troops go
out which is a possibility that they're
thinking about they're funding a great
deal of research into this and I believe
that pts that beta blockers are used
immediately post-trauma
to retry to reduce the effects of trauma
in the field whether that's being done
under the aegis of ongoing research I'm
not sure but it is being done with real
people who faced real trauma because
that's where you can figure out whether
it's efficacious I'm not part of the
bioethics centers PTSD project but I
believe that it has now been
persuasively shown that the beta
blockers really do reduce symptoms and
that that's been done with people who've
really faced trauma and I know that the
US military is pouring a lot of research
money at this but I'm not sure whether
they have an active program of giving
beta blockers to troops when they return
home yes ma'am yeah sure I don't know
you'd have to go out and find all the
people who are on them and and and and
ask them about their exposure to trauma
and then try to figure out if the rate
among that population was different from
people who are exposed to trauma who
aren't on beta blockers it's that seems
like it might be hard to do but but
there is a lot of study on human
subjects being done in this area
partly because funding is flowing from
the military and partly because people
are beginning to appreciate the
prevalence among victims of household
abuse rape victims first responders who
find bodies and things like that is very
high
police officers have a big problem with
it farming so there is a lot of
experimentation being done on human
beings and as far as I know there's not
much question about beta-blockers
working the debate is about whether how
widely they should be accepted as a kind
of a automatic response to the
possibility of a stressful interaction
yes right so this is this is one of the
places where there's a lot of ethical
debate is that it's an important human
characteristic that we face enormous
stress and have guilt and anxiety about
doing terrible things or seeing terrible
things and that's possibly an adaptive
feature of us that that gets us to do
fewer terrible things and gets us to try
to avoid places where terrible things
occur so part of the ethical debate is
that if these are begun begin to be used
prophylactically it might lead us down a
path where we're undermining people's
self-control where we are over utilizing
our military in situations that we can
predict are going to be terrible or well
we're just for all those patients who
see the stressful things and don't
develop the symptoms of PTSD in some way
we might have deprived them of a
personality forming and personality
changing traumatic experience so all
these questions about how much your
memory is tied to your self hood and
whether it matters that your memory is
fairly clinical or whether it needs to
be one of these sock you in the gut
emotional memories to really be part of
you that's that's a lot of where if the
ethics debate is yes sir
yes the carrying mother is the one who
has an abortion right in that case no
one else right the only the there's only
one kind of case in American law where
men have much say about whether children
will be born or not and that is the case
where there's a frozen embryo and a
couple have split up and mom says this
is my last chance at having a child as
biologically related to me I want to
implant that frozen embryo and dad says
I don't want to have any children with
you that's why we're divorced and the
result there in all six states in the US
have looked at this and all six states
have said dad's desire not to have
children
Trump's mom's desire to have this last
shot at a biologically related child
it's often a case where Mama's had a
hysterectomy or has had cancer therapy
that's left her infertile but these
frozen embryos are left over from an
earlier attempt and in those cases the
courts have gone with the men same thing
happened in England Israel went the
other way and went with the woman who
wanted the child and I'm informed that
that has something to do with Israeli
law and the idea that Judaism passes
matrilineal II and therefore there's
greater priority in the decision in the
mom but most countries it's only the
woman who's carrying the child who gets
to decide about whether or not the child
will be born yes or in the green yeah
well medical tourism they're calling it
and there's a there's a wide variety of
it there is a black market in organs
Americans go around to South and Central
America to India and get organs that
have been
procured who knows how and they get them
implanted by Western trained physicians
who get paid a fee for this and I might
comment on the ethics of that is that
it's bad and it's bad for it's for
several reasons but one of the more
important reasons is that the organ
donor the organ is often someone who
sold an organ and the conditions of that
sale and the conditions of the surgery
that was used to remove the organ and so
on are all happening in the dark and all
not subject to regulation and all
potentially exploitative and terrible we
have all kinds of other bits of medical
tourism going on however you can go to
Switzerland to commit suicide it's legal
there you can actually some insurance
companies they're not yet forcing anyone
to do this but they're offering that
patients the opportunity to have
surgeries be done in India with American
trained physicians because the total
cost because the capital costs of the
surgical suites and so on are so much
smaller that they can afford to fly you
to India and keep you in a very fancy
hotel and have the surgery done over
there and have you recover over there
with full-time nursing care in a nice
atmosphere and it cost about one third
as the same surgery here so we may yet
see the day when medical tourism becomes
completely common because it saves you a
lot more than the travel cost and then
we have to worry about whether their
medical ethics are the same as our
medical ethics and who does the informed
consent and who pays and yeah there's a
lot going on about that yes right right
behind this man [ __ ] one more question
you're it yes
mostly I think not I mean there are
there are certainly rules and there have
been rules for a while about the
creation and handling of anything that
might be a biohazard there are all kinds
of regulatory control to prevent lab
escapes of potentially hazardous
material and so on but this doesn't I
think most of the researchers who work
in the field think about it as just very
cool manipulation of very tiny things
and they were thinking about downstream
industrial applications and so on but
they're not they're not focused on the
huge ethical picture there is debate
around this and the researchers are
aware of it but I don't think apart from
the ordinary ethical guidelines that
govern scientific endeavor about honesty
and reproducibility of results and
biohazard control and publication and
you know responsible conduct of research
all of those things are in place the way
they're in place for every kind of cell
science or or genomic science but there
isn't yet any kind of special code
around the project of synthetic biology
I'm afraid we're out of time
in fact we're more than out of time but
not by much